what would happen if there was a
full-scale nuclear war between Russia
and the United States
Based on non-classified data the
aftermath might go something like this
when one side launches nuclear missiles
the other side detects them and fires
back before impact
U.S submarine launched ballistic
missiles from west of Norway start
striking Russia after about 10 minutes
and Russian ones from north of Canada
start hitting the U.S a few minutes
later
the very first strikes are high altitude
EMP attacks frying electronics and power
grids by creating an electromagnetic
pulse of tens of thousands of volts per
meter
the next strikes Target command and
control as well as nuclear launch
facilities
land-based intercontinental ballistic
missiles take about half an hour to
arrive major cities are targeted both
because they contain military facilities
and to stymie the enemy's post-war
recovery
some cruise missiles take hours to reach
their target
each impact creates a fireball about as
hot as the core of the Sun followed by a
radioactive mushroom cloud these intense
explosions vaporize people nearby and
cause fires and blindness further away
the fireball expansion then causes a
blast wave that damages buildings
crushing nearby once the United Kingdom
and France have nuclear capabilities and
are obliged by NATO's Article 5 to
defend the U.S
so Russia hits them too
firestorms engulf many cities where
Storm level winds fan the Flames
igniting anything that can burn melting
glass and some metals and turning
asphalt into flammable hot liquid but
the explosions the electromagnetic pulse
and the radioactivity aren't the worst
part nuclear winter is caused by the
black carbon smoke from the nuclear
firestorms
the Hiroshima atomic bomb caused such a
firestorm but today's hydrogen bombs are
much more powerful a large city like
Moscow with almost 50 times more people
can create much more smoke
and a firestorm sends plumes of black
smoke up into the stratosphere far above
any rain clouds that would otherwise
wash out the smoke this Black Smoke Gets
heated by sunlight lofting it like a hot
air balloon for up to a decade high
altitude jet streams are so fast that it
takes only a few days for the smoke to
spread across much of the northern
hemisphere
in the meantime Earth gets freezing cold
even during the summer with Farmland in
Kansas cooling by about 20 degrees
Centigrade or 40 degrees Fahrenheit and
other regions cooling almost twice as
much
a recent scientific paper estimates that
over 5 billion people could starve to
death including around 99 percent of
those in the United States Europe
Russia
and China
we obviously don't know how many people
will survive a nuclear war
but if it's even remotely as bad as
scientists think then it has no winners
merely losers
see to feel powerless but the good news
is that there is something you can do to
help please share this video
because the more people know about
nuclear war the less likely it is that
we'll start one
foreign
[Music]